lick knight of brown coal has long been
at the center of environmental protests
called the dirtiest form of gold it has
been providing power to the german
economy and households for decades under
pressure from the green party the new
government announced it aims to close
these open pit mines by 2030 but that
was before russia invaded ukraine
it's clear that a terrible war in
ukraine means we are realizing that our
electricity supply in germany wasn't and
isn't very secure and there are several
possible risk factors that applies to
gas oil and to hard coal too and there
are of course some who are now thinking
there's a domestic energy source which
will always be available as well as wind
and sun of course and that's lignite to
make sure there's enough energy in
future winters that regional government
in brandenburg has asked permission to
keep some lignite-powered plants on
standby
to have the necessary supply for the
coming winter season
and that hopefully without any
dependence of imports from russia that
problem has still not been solved
and
in turn as as i'm coming from the field
of industrial safety i would prefer to
have a situation with belt and parachute
and so it would be worthwhile to keep
them
available
ukraine has accused germany of financing
russia's war because of its dependency
on russian gas oil and coal the eu has
decided to ban coal imports which will
cost russia around 4 billion euros a
year in comparison a ban on russian gas
and oil would cost the country 80
billion euros
this is one of the few power stations in
germany not depending on imports from
russia domestically produced lignite is
one of the most reliable sources germany
has but also one of the most polluting
it was unthinkable just a few months ago
that the new government in which greens
play an important role would even
consider using more coal but the war in
ukraine has changed everything and the
climate could be another victim
more co2 emissions instead of less an
uncomfortable reality for environmental
groups who have long campaigned for an
end to coal use
germany for a long period of time has
sponsored the russian regime the
oligarchy in russia and has put russia
in a position to finance that war
unfortunately we cannot get rid of that
dependency overnight it's obviously a
bitter pill we have old cold power
plants that have to get back on the grid
but we have to accelerate the build out
of renewables this needs some years but
the german industry now has a clear
target that its future is based on
renewable energy but building wind farms
and solar panels takes time and germany
is under pressure to act now that
pressure will only grow if terrible
images continue to come out of ukraine
and the eu decides to go further and ban
russian oil and gas step faster than al
jazeera in brandenburg